نحن نأخذ حوامة إلى بعض
الأماكن الأكثر شهرة هنا على بحيرة بايكال ،
إنها
طبيعة نقية للغاية والكثير منها الآن
تحت تهديد
إنها بحيرة عملاقة
ومن الواضح أنها نظام بيئي مهم للغاية
للحيوانات النادرة هنا
وخاصة
الحياة البرية بايكال  هي واحدة من
1112 موقعًا للتراث العالمي لليونسكو
وهي معالم ثقافية وطبيعية
يُنظر إليها على أنها
ذات قيمة بارزة للإنسانية
وهي تقود بشكل أساسي فوق بحيرة متجمدة
[موسيقى]
وهو الموسم الذي تعرف أن البحيرة فيه
مجمدة إلى حد يمكنك
فعلاً المضي فيه  لقد أصبح هذا
أقصر وأقصر ،
لكن تغير المناخ ليس هو المشكلة الوحيدة
التي تواجه هذه البحيرة ،
يتساءل بعض المسؤولين عما إذا كانت روسيا
تضحي بالحماية البيئية من
أجل الإيرادات مما يسمح للسياحة
والتنمية بإجهاد نظام
بيئي هش بالفعل ، وتستمر السياحة الجماعية هنا
في بحيرة بايكال في
النمو  هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين نتحدث معهم ويقولون إن
بحيرة بايكال لا يمكنها ببساطة استيعاب المزيد من
الأشخاص
[الموسيقى]
مع
[Musi  ج]
[موسيقى]
كانت هناك زيادة هائلة في عدد
زوار بحيرة بايكال في السنوات الأخيرة في
موسم الشتاء الماضي ،
حيث تضاعف عدد السياح
وفقًا لرئيس
وكالة السياحة الروسية على الرغم من ارتفاع
عدد القتلى في روسيا البالغ 19 شخصًا ،
والذي يشجعه  الحكومة
من أجل تعزيز
الاقتصاد ، يبدو أن الكثير من أعمال البناء
تجري هنا لم يكن قانونيًا حقًا ما
كان يحدث على أي حال ، ثم اضطر إلى
إيقاف الأشخاص الذين حاولوا الحصول على
تصاريح للمنازل الخاصة التي تعرفها
لبناء منزل خاص وبدلاً من ذلك
بناء أو  ابدأ في بناء فندق ،
فإن أطلال البناء هذه ليست مجرد
قبيح للعين ولكن الكثير منها
تعلم أن البناء غير القانوني
سيء حقًا للبيئة هنا
مياه الصرف الصحي غير المعالجة التي تذهب إلى البحيرة مثل أوه
في الخلف
هناك الجليد رائع حقًا وأزرق ولكن في
الجزء الأمامي هنا
يمكنك أن ترى أنه في الواقع نوع من
الأصفر ويبدو نوعًا من الإجمالي
وهذا في الواقع لأن هذه
مياه الصرف الصحي التي تم تجميدها تأتي من
m نهر أم
هنا حيث تتدفق مياه الصرف الصحي غير المفلترة
في أشهر الصيف من الواضح أنه يتدفق
مباشرة إلى بحيرة بايكال
[موسيقى
] الآن نحن في رحلة بالسيارة مدتها ثلاث ساعات
من إيركوتسك وهي بالطبع المدينة الرئيسية
حول هذه المنطقة
لشراء خالصة  ما لديك هناك
هو في الأساس بطاقة قنبلة موقوتة بيئية ،
وهناك مصنع ورق قديم هناك
تم إغلاقه في عام 2013 حيث
كان يعمل منذ الستينيات ، وهو
بالفعل يتسرب من مياه الصرف الصحي إلى بحيرة
بايكال ، مما أدى إلى
تلويث مجموعة من المنطقة التي
نقوم بتصويرها هنا الآن.  ربما يتعين عليك
القيام بذلك بسرعة كبيرة لأنني
لست متأكدًا من أن السلطات هنا
ستكون سعيدة جدًا حيال ذلك ،
فأنت تمتلك المصنع القديم
نفسه
ومن ثم لديك الخزانات التي تحتوي
على
نفايات سامة فيها حيث من الواضح أنك
تواجه خطرًا  أن بعضًا من ذلك يمكن أن
يتسرب إلى البحيرة الفعلية عن طريق الاتصال
[الموسيقى]
وهذا أمر خطير للغاية على هذا النظام البيئي
هنا
لديك مراحيض يتم إعدادها
بجوار صخرة الشامان القديمة هنا
أي الناس بالطبع ليسوا سعداء
هنا وأعتقد أن الكثير منهم لا يؤمنون
بأن ثقافتهم أه يتم
احترامها بالطريقة التي
ينبغي أن يحترمها الناس ، وقد أخبرنا الناس أن هناك المزيد
والمزيد من السياح يأتون إلى هنا ويخشون
حقًا ذلك مرة واحدة  ينتهي الوباء
أنه يمكن أن يكون أكثر مما
تعلم أن السكان المحليين يقولون نعم
بالطبع
هناك فائدة للاقتصاد في كل
هذا ولكن هل يريدون
المزيد من السياحة أو هل يريدون حقًا
بذل جهد للحفاظ على طبيعتهم